copy inbound mission copy tenth of a  meter per second at this point you can  see that the service section Draco's  just doing all these very small minor  attitude Corrections really the the  autonomous docking system at work making  sure that the the vestibule and the self  capture system is lined up with ID a to  the international docking adaptor one  meter to go  soft capture complete capture confirmed  stand by for retraction and donkey  dragon arriving crew of expedition 63 is  hard to welcome dragon in the Commercial  Crew program - welcome aboard the  International Space Station Bob and Doug  glad to have you as part of the crew  well done fellas ooh